نعم ليلى الكل يحاول ان يساعد بطريقته في
ظل العدد المحدود من سيارات الاسعاف انا
ما اراهم اشدهم منذ سعات الصباح وحتى هذه
اللحظه ثلاث الى اربع سيارات اسعاف هي
التي تعمل تحديدا وتاتي بالاصابات الى
مجمع ناصر الطبي سواء التابع لوزاره الصحه
او الدفاع المدني الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
قال صباح اليوم ان مركز الاسعاف التابع
للجمعيه في مدينه خانيونس والواقع في حي
الامل هو يتعرض لحصار من قبل دبابات
واليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وان
الهلال حر فقد الاتصال في مركز الاسعاف في
خنس وانهم لا يستطيعون التحرك الى خارج
مستشفى الامل ومركز الاسعاف في حي الامل
الى مناطق متفرقه من مدينه خانيونس نتيجه
القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه المتواصله على
مدينه خانيونس هناك ان كنا نتحدث حتى هذه
اللحظه عن 43 شهيدا هناك عشرات اخرين من
الشهداء لازالوا ملقون على الارض في مناطق
متفرقه هذا هو الوضع دا
السياره تح او تنتشل هي مزيد من ال الجر
هي ذات السياره انا ما شاهدته منذ ساعات
الصباح وحتى الان ثلاث سيارات اسعاف فقط
هي التي تعمل وتنتشل الجثامين الشهداء
مناطق متفرقه من مدينه خانيونس وايضا
اجلاء عائلات من مصابه باكملها الاب والام
والاطفال ياتون بهم الى هنا الى مستشفى
نصر الامكانيات محدوده جدا جدا في قسم
الاستقبال والطوارئ في ناصر الكوادر
الطبيه عددها قليل جدا مقابل الاعداد
الكبيره التي تصل على مدار الساعه سواء
عبر هذه سياره الاسعاف او عبر عربات نقل
بدائيه وعبر سيارات
مدنيه وفي ظل النقص الكبير في الموارد
الطبيه والامكانيات والادويه وحتى
العلاج ما وصلت هي اصابه خطيره في الصدر
نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي قرب مستشفى ناصر الطبي
الوضع حتى على الصعيد الصحي هو وضع صعب
للغايه
عدم توفر كوادر طبيه كافيه امام هذه
الاعداد الكبيره من الاصابات عدم توفر
سيارات اسعاف لانقاذ حياه الناس المحاصرين
داخل منازلهم نتيجه تواصل القصف المدفع
والغارات الاسرائيليه عدم توفر الادويه
عدم توفر الغرف العمليات الكافيه لاجرائها
لاجراء عمليات جراحيه خاصه للمصابين بجروح
خطيره الين يصلون الى مستشفى ناصر علاوه
على استمرار الاشتباكات والقصف اذا سمحت
مؤمن فقط اشير الى ما جاء عن المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه ان الاحتلال
يستهدف 30 ال نازح في خمسه مراكز ايواء في
خان يونس كذلك خبر اخر عن سرايا القدس
بانها استهدفت اليه عسكريه صهيونيه بقذيفه
ار بي جي وسط مدينه خانيونس اذا هذه اخر
الاخبار من
الميدان تفضل
مؤمن
حمدان على الصعيد الميداني هنا في مدينه
خانيونس الاشتباكات والقصف المدفع
الاشتباكات في اكثر من محور مدينه خانيونس
في المحور الجنوبي الشرقي في المنطقه
الغربيه التي توغلت اليها دبابات جيش
الاحتلال وايضا في محيط منطقه البلد حيث
يتواجد عدد من قناصه جيش الاحتلال يعتلون
الابنيه المرتفعه بالاضافه الى شارع
القسام المؤدي الى منطقه البلد وشارع خمسه
ومنطقه الكتيبه كل هذه بالاضافه الى
المحور الشرقي ببلدته المختلفه من بني
سهيله الى الزنه الى معا كل هذه محاور
اشتباك مشتعله بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ بدء
العمليه البريه وحتى هذه اللحظه المقاومه
تحاول استخدام كافه الوسائل المتاحه لديها
من الصواريخ المضاده للدروع من العبوات
الناسفه من نصب الكمائن لمنع تقدم الالي
وتوغل اكثر في مختلف المحاور اسرائيل دمرت
يوم امس مربعات سكنيه جديده اليوم السادس
على التوالي اسرائيل دمرت اكثر من مربع
السكني نسمع الدوي انفجار كبير في المنطقه
الغربيه لمجمع ناصر الطبي نتمنى ان تاخذ
مكانا امما او طرفا على الاقل بعيدا عن
هذه الغاره الجديده لو سمحت مؤمن ساتركك
هي
شضايا شضايا شضايا القصف شضايا القصف في
المنطقه فك فك الكاميرا فك الكاميرا خلينا
نشوف خليكم
معنا ك نحن معك ان هناك
استهداف اما داخل
المستشفى او في المنطقه اتاكد
بسرعه سمعنا دوي انفجار كبير وقريب جدا
اما ان يكون من بجانب الور الغربي
للمستشفى او داخل الصور الغربي داخل يعني
حرم مستشفى ناصر حتى ان شضايا هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه تطايرت في المكان الذي نقف
فيه ولا ندري
طبيعه بس الشبا وق على الناس
هي بحمد لله هي بجوار السور الغربي
لمستشفى ناصر الطبي الا ان
شضايا هذه الغاره و شضايا الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه سقطت على خيام للنازحين في
الساحه الغربيه لمستشفى ناصر وايضا حتى
انها وصلت الى امام قسم الاستقبال و
الطوارئ في مدينه الجميع
الجميع الجميع
في دائره استهداف الاسرائيليه والقصف يطال
جميع المرافق سواء محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي
او مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر او حتى المستشفى الاوروبي الى
الجنوب الشرقي من مدينه خانيونس كل
المرافق الطبيه وحتى مراكز الاواء المدارس
التابعه للاونروا هي باتت في مرمى اما
قذائف المدفعيه او
صواريخ الطائرات الحربيه او حتى الطائرات
المصيره التي يستخدمها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيل بكثافه خلال الايام الماضيه من
نوع كواد كابتر التي تطلق النار على
المواطنين وعلى كل من يتحرك تحديدا في
ساعات المساء اومن يحاول الوصول الى مناطق
تتواجد فيها اليات جيش الاحتلال لانتشال
جثامين الشهداء الوضع في عمومه ليلى في
مدينه خانيونس هو وضع صعب للغايه صعب
للغايه على الصعيد الانساني اتحدث على
صعيد ايضا الصحي على صعيد النازحين ونحن
اي
مع دخول خلال الساعات القادمه يدخل منخفض
جوي جديد يضرب
المنطقه حتى يبلغني احد المسعفين ان انهم
يضطرون الى
اجلاء الجرحى والشهداء من المناطق البينيه
بين رفح وخان يونس الى المستشفى الكويتي
لصعوبه الاوضاع هنا في مستشفى ناصر الطبي
وتكدس اعداد كبيره من الجرحى وايضا تكدس
اعداد الشهداء يضطرون الى نقل الاصابات
والشهداء في المناطق القريبه من مدينه رفح
والبينيه بين رفح وخانيونس الى المستشفى
الكويتي في مدينه
رفح والاستهداف كما يخبرنا الزملاء انه
منزل ملاصق للجدار الغربي لمدينه لمستشفى
ناصر